I was happy to accept the invitation to
speak to conceptual foundations which I
have done once before to an earlier
generation of mi A's I think two years
ago or three years ago um then I spoke
mainly about the book that I asked you
to read as part of your assignment for
today today I will be talking to you
about the book I am currently working on
or at least what I will talk to you
about today draws on the book I'm
currently working on which is about the
cold war in the Middle East the United
States and the cold war in the Middle
East and so my topic which is
alternative views of American premise II
will base itself on the readings that I
asked you to look at the my book and the
Meyer book the Charles Meyer book um but
also the work that I'm currently doing
on the cold war in the Middle East I'm
gonna talk this afternoon I hope for
less than an hour around four main
points the first is in the current
unipolar international system what
exactly is the role of the United States
what is the role of the United States in
this current unipolar system that's my
first question
first focus this afternoon's talk my
second hinges around the question is the
United States and Empire and if so when
did it become one um and this is another
question I have been thinking about for
a long time you can see it reflected in
resurrecting Empire um but it is a
question I've been thinking about since
I finished that book more than one
almost four years ago now three and a
half years ago my third question more of
a historical question is how does this
unipolar system different from the
bipolar system which characterized the
Cold War period and which differed
greatly obviously from the multipolar
system that preceded it in others before
World War two how does the system we
have today where the United States is
clearly the dominant power
you know folder system how does it
differ from the bipolar system the Cold
War I will suggest perhaps less than we
may think and finally where is this all
going one of the cheapest lines that I I
favor and talks is to say that as a
historian my job description does not
include predicting the future and I'm
not going to predict the future I'm just
gonna suggest you what in the past and
in the present might we look at to
understand where we might be going so
let me start by talking about the
situation of the United States and the
current international system what
precisely is that situation is it a
situation of hegemony whatever that word
means is it is it a situation of primacy
as the title of the lecture suggests is
it simply the dominant power temporary
position which might change in a short
board or medium in the short or medium
term or is it as an imperial power
whatever that term means um clearly
since the decline and then the
disappearance of the Soviet Union the
United States has been essentially
unchallenged in the international system
what what has it done with this new
status of unchallenged dominant power um
for the first few years after the
collapse of the USSR and of the Soviet
bloc and of any real power
capable of challenging the power of the
United States um it did not seem
entirely clear where the United States
was going I'm gonna talk first about the
administration of George Herbert Walker
Bush the president's the current
president's father I'll talk briefly
about the Clinton administration and
then I will talk about the current
administration to show Oh what I mean
when I say that it did not initially
seem entirely clear where the United
States was going the president who
presided over the disappearance of the
Soviet Union he came into office in
January of 1981 89 and the Soviet Union
was in full disintegration at this it
disappeared the following year George
Herbert Walker Bush in fact did appear
as if he had some sense of the historic
nature of what was occurring on his
watch both he and his secretary of state
were astute of practitioners of
international politics they were people
who had a great deal of experience there
were people who were if not highly
articulate if not visionary if not
charismatic certainly a clear and with a
certain sense of how the world operates
and so it was the first president of
course who talked about a new world
order
emerging from the post-soviet situation
of a premise II of the United States at
the same time even though he talked
about a new world order which would
involve peace and cooperation that was
the nature of that speech if you go back
to it this president was willing to use
overwhelming force to restore the status
quo ante bellum in quit after the Iraqi
occupation in the 1991 first Gulf War
this was in many ways a response which
looked like a simple restoration of the
old Westfall Westphalian state system
the state system that emerged from the
Treaty of Westphalia in 1648 where the
modern state system was created he was
just putting back what had been
disrupted by the aggression of the Iraqi
regime under Saddam Hussein it seemed in
other words on the one hand as if this
was not a in any way a departure this
was a an action that was run by the
United Nations Security Council approved
by the United Nations Security Council
this was an action in which so many
countries participated that it's almost
impossible to enumerate them every major
American allied was involved including a
vast range of countries in the Middle
East every neighbor of Iraq participated
overtly or covertly in this operation
and it was thoroughly justified in terms
of the UN Charter so it was not only a
restoration of the Westphalian state
system it was also something that was
done in terms of the post-world War two
international structure that had been
established by the victors in that war
on the other hand by any measure at the
end of this war
the united states has massively
increased its presence and its profile
in the middle east this was a radical
change some of the people who opposed
this war including my then colleague at
the University of Chicago John
Mearsheimer said at the time and have
said since the reason for opposing this
war was not the specifics of great that
was a situation that had to be resolved
that aggression had to be turned back it
was that he argued once the United
States went in it would never go out he
is proven right
in a certain respect in any case this
these actions notwithstanding and
President Bush the first president Bush
avocation of a new world order
notwithstanding I think he can be argued
that that four-year presidential term
did not see the United States setting
out on a clear unambiguous course for
the post Cold War era the same thing can
be said of the succeeding eight years of
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton came into
office in January 1993 his
administration had if it had a sense of
a new post Cold War world that sense
seemed to be mainly dominated by focus
on economics and trade the idea if there
was an idea there and it's hard to tell
whether there really was an organizing
idea under the Clinton administration
about how to see the world in the post
Cold War era the idea seemed to be that
this new world would be knit together in
some way economically or technologically
and that no particular attention was
required to how the United States would
manage its newfound status as a hegemon
or a country that had primacy or
whatever the United States was there was
I would argue no vision at all if
President the first President Bush had a
certain vision but it's not clear where
exactly that when I would argue the
Clinton administration had no vision at
all didn't help that it was adorned by
two of the least charismatic sectors of
state in modern history
Christopher Warren Christopher and
Madeleine Albright however in the Middle
East which I will come back to again and
again not just because this is the area
of my ex
tee's but because I think it plays a
particularly important role I played an
important role in the Cold War and I
think it plays a particularly important
role in the post-cold war world the
United States had a huge profile under
Clinton as well just as under the first
president Bush the United States had led
this huge coalition and established a
large presence in the region and even
larger presence in the region so under
President Clinton did the United States
play a very major role in terms of
arab-israeli negotiations during the
entirety of the Clinton presidency
negotiations which of course had been
started under the first Bush
administration but which were brought to
fruition under Clinton and it also
maintained a ferocious sanctions regime
in Iraq which helped in the destruction
of that country the ongoing destruction
of that country which has been completed
since the invasion and occupation of the
country but which was largely
accomplished by the ten years of
systematic dismantling of the country's
infrastructure through sanctions as well
as continuous error aerial bombardment
and so forth the United States had an
enormous presence it established the
Kurdish autonomous zone in the north of
Iraq it continued to fly over the
country throughout and intervene
militarily in Iraq even though it didn't
occupy the country and it maintained as
I've said this sanctions regime all of
this was to have ominous results as time
went on and I've already said that I
will come back to why I think the Middle
East seems so important in the post-cold
war world as it was in the Cold War
whether it's argued that this is an
important fulcrum of world power because
of its location whether it's argued that
it's because of the energy resources it
contains whether for some other reason
it's sort of a canary in the coal mine I
in the coal mine I think we will see
that the Middle East plays a
particularly important role in this in
this post Cold War Europe finally let us
come to the administration of George W
Bush which began in January of 2001 in
many people's view I'm not entirely sure
I share this but I share it in part in
many people's view this administration
has changed the behavior
in the world in fundamental ways in
resurrecting Empire I talked about one
of these ways invading occupying and
dismantling the government of a major
Middle Eastern country is something the
United States had never done in its
history done similar things in Central
Asia
in much smaller countries but it had
never done such a thing to a major
Middle Eastern state at any time in
American history nor had it done such a
thing in many other parts of the world
um this to my way of thinking buying of
itself marked a departure what then
followed the installation of very large
a number of us spaces not only in Iraq
but in a whole swath the establishment
of bases which were I'm sure we're all
aware of insofar as Iraq is concerned
did not just take place in Iraq or for
that matter in Afghanistan it's taken
place in a score of countries running
across Africa northern and western
Africa through the Middle East and well
into Central Asia
there's a new command the African
command which is part of this there's a
whole new structure whereby the United
States manages its military power in
this part of the world all of this was
done in particularly the invasion of
Iraq without international sanction all
of it was done against the wishes of
many key US allies including most US
allies in the region and several major
European and other powers and it seemed
to many as an assertion a new and more
intense form of unilateralism in terms
of the u.s. role in the world we have to
understand it as being coupled with a
new national security doctrine that
advocated preemption and preventive war
all of this using 9/11 essentially as a
pretext because whatever happened on
9/11 had very little to do with the
state that we're talking about Iraq and
with a much more unilateral much less
checked must much less balanced
executive branch insofar as
foreign-policy war-making powers of the
president and surveillance of citizens
was concerned in all of these areas what
had previously been argued were the
necessary checks and balances on the
executive seem to have gone by the board
um this coupled with all of this these
things this move into the Middle East
into North Africa and it's inset into
Central Asia can be argued to have
marked a new departure in scope in size
and intensity even if the United States
has had an uninterrupted military
presence in the Middle East since 1942
that is the case since I hate 42 for 65
years now they're having at some in some
place in the Middle East then American
forces and American bases since American
forces landed in North Africa in 1942
and landed in Iran in that same year
there's always been an American military
presence but the change in terms of size
scope and intensity was remarkable now
in resurrecting Empire I try to suggest
that the United States sometimes appears
to be playing almost an old-fashioned
colonial role clearly deploying less
expertise or less less competent
expertise clearly deploying considerably
more power and clearly operating in a
very different international situation
in an international situation in which
colonialism is a bad word
even if Empire is not necessarily by
contrast American dominance has
previously never been exercised in this
part of the world in precisely this way
it was previously exercised more
indirectly it was previously exercised
at least in the Middle East and other
regions like Africa South America and
some other parts of the world in ways
which did not involve what appears to be
not just an invasion of a country or an
occupation of a country but a complete
refashioning of the country in the image
of the occupying power I could tell you
interesting stories about things the
United States thought it was going to do
about healthcare in Iraq they wanted to
give them hm arms they actually walked
into that country thinking that this was
what we
going to do in Iraq they were gonna
bless them with the wonders of insurance
companies bless them with the wonders of
HMOs bless them with the wonderful
billing system that we have bless them
with the hundreds of thousands of
bureaucrats who eat up a huge proportion
of our healthcare dollar that was
actually what they were gonna do and
that's just one tiny itty-bitty little
piece of the picture they win it and
taught them about a common law system in
a country which does not have common law
they went in and told them about the
privatization of their oil industry in a
country which has fought against foreign
control of their oil for the moment the
country was established they were trying
to remould that country in their image
that may not be old-fashioned
colonialism but it certainly was
reminiscent of that to the Iraqis now
you might argue well in places like the
Dominican Republic in places like
Grenada in places like Panama and in
earlier interventions in Central America
the Caribbean the Philippines the United
States did just that but the United
States did those things in that limited
sphere United States was a Caribbean
Central American and Pacific Power until
World War two it had never done or even
tried to do any such thing elsewhere
before World War two and even after
World War two its interventions were
generally speaking covert elsewhere in
the United States generally s truth
avoided this form of intervention
military invasion occupation imposition
of a new government long-term basis an
attempt to establish control in some
form direct or indirect of the country's
major resource which is oil now let me
conclude this section by saying that
it's not at all clear how much of this
is really new did what the Bush
administration do in terms of unleashing
unleashing the executive from the
trammels of congressional checks and
balances make that much of a difference
was the Bush administration's act much
more unilateral than previous American
administrations was acting without
allies or acting without the United
United Nations so entirely different
I'll leave that to you to think about um
it has been argued that it is and that
cumulatively this represents a major
shift or me
step upwards but I think it is
questionable at least whether that's the
case secondly it's not at all clear how
long this posture will continue after
this administration leaves office in
January 2009 to what extent are these
permanent changes in the way in which
the United States approaches the world
will the American national security
doctrine remain the same will the
American footprint in the Middle East
remain the same will the American
attempt to link everything and
everywhere that happens to terrorism and
thereby and thereby justified American
responses continue in a future
administration it much obviously would
depend on who the leader the president
and his or her administration is but I
think these are questions that are worth
asking finally it's not even clear to me
whether all of this is sustainable even
in the short term between now and
January 2009 I'm not entirely sure that
we're going to see this situation
continue even for the rest of this
presidency I will leave you with those
questions and move on now to my second
major point is the United States truly
an empire and if so how did it become
one um part of the definition of empire
there is meant there as many definitions
of empire as there are definers and I'm
not going to give you mine but I'll list
a few of the factors I think probably
should be considered if we are thinking
about whether the United States is an
empire and thinking about what an empire
is part of I think anybody's good
definition of empire has to do with a
system of law a legal system think of
the Roman Empire think of Shelley outlaw
think of the Chinese legal system these
are clear pillars of an imperial system
another aspect of Empire has to do with
culture a shared culture that is either
imposed on or is imitated on by subjects
peoples or by peoples who are not
necessarily subjects read about the way
in which people across the border from
the Roman Empire were in effect
romanized and you'll see the power and
attraction of an imperial culture and
the Chinese and the Muslim empires are
perfect examples I think of both
processes having very powerful legal
systems and very powerful cultural
attraction which operated of even across
their own frontiers Europe was in thrall
to Islamic philosophy countries all
around China aided and imitate even
countries that had not been subjugated
by China aimed and imitated Chinese
cultural forms Japan Korea the Korea of
course was subjugated by China for a
very long period but Japan never was
conquered and yet it imitated the
Chinese example these are these are
cases where I think law legal system and
also the administrative system that
follows from that as well as culture are
certainly important elements in Empire
and I think they're important era
elements in the way in which the United
States relates to the rest of the world
in a book that I might have assigned to
you I had I read it in time a book by
Colin Murphy it's really a long essay
entitled are we wrong the fall of an
empire and the fate of America the
author suggests another I think
important pillar of Empire this is a
standing professional military force
that is mobile and properly funded and
most good historians of Empire will
agree on this can't have an empire
without a standing army and a standing
army means a sustainable financial
mechanism to put troops in the field all
over in all directions at all times in a
way that will not change with a change
in leadership a change in administration
a change in government to change an
emperor or whatever all of these things
the United States has obviously plus
others and I would lay a great deal of
stress on one aspect of American
hegemony whether this amounts to Empire
or not is another question and this is
the post-world War to financial
arrangements essentially engineered by
the United States at Bretton Woods and
afterwards establishing the
International Monetary Fund establishing
the World Bank and later on leading to
things like the World Trade Organization
various free trade agreements all of
these are the superstructure of an
economic system with which with the
exception of the Soviet bloc for the
brief period of the Cold War became you
know
versal they were linked to a legal
system which is connected to that
economic system obviously that legal
system didn't penetrate into other
states England still has common-law
France still operates on a legal system
based on the Napoleonic Code and so
forth but for interchanges between
states more and more American legal
system is the basis of law and all of
this I think indicates a enormous set of
advantages for the United States whether
again this constitutes Empire is another
question one more characteristic of
Empire and this is actually crucial and
I think this is where the debate has to
center one more characteristic of Empire
is a sense of mission and an acceptance
of this as part of the self view of the
country or at least of that country's
elite look carefully at past empires
look at the Ottoman Empire look at
obviously the Rome or China but look at
the hob sporks look at the British
Empire the sense that there was a
mission the sense that this is part of
the the way of people sees itself the
sense that this is one in a chain of
empires is clearly an important part of
Empire it's not a coincidence that the
British ruling class was taught not only
Greek and Latin classics but was taught
the model of Greece and Rome and in
particular the model of Rome such that
you could have British Prime Minister's
like Palmerston who would say it in
terms of an extension of British power
in the Mediterranean as it happened in
the done Pacifico affair of 1852 Q was
Roman assume I am a Roman citizen ie
this man done pacifica who was
maltreated would be protected by the
British state just as the Roman Empire
would protect any Roman citizen anywhere
in the world this sense of continuity
with other imperial missions and this
sense of mission is clearly part of an
empire now there is a great debate in
this country on the topic of empire
I'm happy to see it a lot of books are
being sold I'm happy when books are sold
I think that's a good thing
books are good I'm not saying internet
television are bad Genet in television
sell books alright but it's an
indication that people are thinking that
there's been such a proliferation of
publishing on this subject of empire
some of it is of course repetitive some
of it is turgid some of it is is jargon
laden but some of it is really quite
intelligent and there is a debate not
just about Empire in general but from
Neil Ferguson to a whole range of other
authors some of them quite eminent the
question of whether the United States is
an empire and what constitutes an empire
and whether we're approaching this has
become an enormous topic topic of debate
Neil Ferguson has one of the most
interesting positions in this a British
historian of British Empire is arguing
that the United States is of course an
empire and saying you nitwits get used
to it accept it shoulder the burdens
that you're carrying whether you
understand it or not you are an empire
behave like one for heaven's sakes grow
up or you have grown up act like yours
on that in essence is what Ferguson is
saying and it is the first time in
American history that not just the
Ferguson's of this world that say
imports from Britain or professors at
Harvard but a whole range of
commentators a whole range of writers at
all levels of society are arguing over
this and saying yes we are an empire no
we're not an empire and for the first
time the term imperial or empire is not
a term of disapprobation in American
public discourse for the first time the
idea that the United States might be an
empire that that might even be a good
thing has at least been broached um now
anyone who knows any American history
knows the United States has always had
an outsize and outsized sense of global
mission go back to the very first
settlers on this continent before they
had even exterminated the native
population before they even mastered the
continent they were talking about a city
on the hill of Beacon unto the unto the
nations
they were talking in terms which made it
clear that they saw that this experiment
was universal
or at least had universal applicability
but they were not talking about applying
it themselves they were not talking
about bringing democracy by gunboat or
by Apache helicopter or whatever they
saw it as a city on a hill they weren't
going to march into the valley to the
next hill
okay it was a beacon to the nation's it
wasn't gonna go and you know with
torches into the nation's so there was
an outsized sense of mission in terms of
what the United States was seen as
embodying but it was something that was
balanced always balanced in the past by
a certain native violation isolationism
by a deep weariness of foreign
entanglements from President
Washington's first sorry from the
farewell speech of President Washington
the first president this warning against
foreign entanglements is a constant
theme from the founders and the framers
of later from other American leaders and
it was always balanced by the checks and
balances instituted by the founders in
the fringes war is made by the executive
the power of the state is expanded
abroad by the executive but the
executive has to get money from Congress
executive has to operate on the basis of
declaration of war to be issued by
Congress and this was all this always
functioned at least in the 18th and the
19th century and into the 20th century
well into the 20th century as a check on
the actions of the executive um now I
would argue that those limitations on
America's unbounded sense of mission in
the world are much weaker today than
they have been at least since the first
half of the 20th century there are many
reasons for this one of them is that the
United States is so much more powerful
only in World War two did Americans
realize just how powerful their country
was the United States didn't even have
an intelligence service before World War
two the United States had no foreign
language expertise before World War two
the United States had a small diplomatic
service and had a very large Navy but
had a limited army and a limited Air
Force after World War two it suddenly
became the biggest in so many
it's most importantly economically the
war spurred the United States until the
point that at the end of the war the
United States produced about half of the
world's GDP the United States was
inordinately superior to all other
countries put together in terms of many
indices of raw power starting in World
War two and obviously that changed the
way people saw themselves I think one of
the most fascinating historical
questions is how that generation of
leadership from the late 30s through the
40s change their view of what the United
States was and how it functioned in the
world and I think that that has to be
understood if we are to understand not
only the Cold War but where we are today
because that is the beginning of the
linking of this outsized sense of
mission of the United States which is
until that point had been restrained in
a variety of ways to global power which
the United States was in a position with
fleets on every sea bases on every
continent to exercise which it did not
have before World War Two the United
States was a Carribean and Pacific Power
before World War two it was not a global
power and it occasionally briefly
intervened in the world in a limited way
and then withdrawn now it was everywhere
in its state everywhere and that changed
everything um I think one thing I want
to touch on before I go on is the
linkage between war and expansion on the
one hand an executive power on the other
I said that the executive has to make
war you can't have a parliament making
more can have a Congress making one you
can't have any kind of deliberative body
making war you have to have a
hierarchical military command headed by
an executive power an executive branch
whoever that is however that's organized
in an autocracy that's easy in a in a in
a in a in an absolute monarchy obviously
that's very simple but in a democracy
it's a little more complicated and if
you look at this it is possible to have
a certain degree of oversight in a
democracy by the representative body
whether it's a Congress or Parliament or
a National Assembly over the expansion
of Empire look at the way in which the
British Parliament tried in some key
successfully managed the expansion of
the British Empire look at the way in
which the French assembly in the 19th
century and into the 20th manage the
expansion of the French Empire look at
our Congress in the wake of the 1890 war
of 8 the spanish-american war of 1898
war however especially modern war is
much harder to manage as I've said you
can't do it by committee especially a
war which involves the entire society
which one or more post Napoleonic war
has increasingly become in this sense
where you have a nation in arms the
elected representative chief executive
who operates within checks and balances
in situation of peace suddenly becomes
not just the president but the commander
in chief this is a term which not
coincidentally this president uses much
much more than almost any but any of his
predecessors and it's not a coincidence
he sees himself as a president at war
but he also sees the power of the
president in a circumstance of war as
being the kinds of powers that an
American president should have and in
the war that without end should always
have this has all kinds of implications
if you think about the historical
precedents for what happens to the
American system think of major
democracies at war in the 20th century
think of say Britain France in the
United States and World War one and
World War two think of clemenceau think
of Lloyd George I think of President
Wilson think of Churchill think of
Roosevelt all of these democratically
elected leaders in well-established
constitutional democracies had the
functional equivalent of dictatorial
powers during these wars in a sense they
had - they were fighting - total wars
against centrally organized foes
Wilhelmina Meany Nazi Germany Japan
during World War two the interesting
thing is that in principle at the end of
the war these powers are supposed to be
handed back and in most cases they were
Lloyd George Churchill lost office soon
after their respective Wars Wilson was
repudiated by the US Senate within two
years of the end of
one in the United States case however
think about it for a second those powers
were not fully revoked why were they not
fully revoked because as soon as World
War two ended the Cold War began as soon
as the war to end all wars ended the
United States entered into a
decades-long
cold war with the Soviet Union and this
obviously prevented the devolution or
the return of powers which the executive
branch had monopolized to Congress or
other parts of government of the Korean
War accentuated and intensified this
process and we eventually had what
Daniel Yergin in one of his earlier
books called the a national security
state a state in which there were
permanent organs of executive power
which in essence were beyond the purview
of Congress so you didn't have checks
and balances look at the defense budget
and ask yourselves is this really under
the control of anybody look at American
intelligence operations are these really
under congressional oversight and what
does that mean what does that mean for
what what the very nice words written
with quill pens in the Constitution um
now having said that I'm not suggesting
that this was an uninterrupted march of
the accretion of executive power of all
people a five-star general form the
president of this institution Dwight the
Eisenhower perceived the danger of this
and in his farewell address
farewell addresses are very good things
in making in his farewell address he
gave one of the most prescient
intelligent far-reaching arguments
against that process describing the
encroachment of what he called a
military-industrial complex and how it
made democratic governance if possible
it's a very important speech by someone
who knew more about the
military-industrial complex than any
American president he commanded the
entirety of US forces of Allied forces
in the Western theater of Europe up to
and through the Normandy invasion and
right up to the defeat of Germany he
knew a lot about the military-industrial
complex and was a
a quite adept wielder of executive power
oh the Vietnam War nevertheless
thereafter greatly expanded these powers
even though Eisenhower in some measure
tried to restrain them and even though
this was followed by a reaction Congress
reacted public opinion reacted to the
Vietnam War and we had a whole series of
Acts that attempted to limit the
untrammeled power of the executive from
the War Powers Act of 1973 to the fore
Intelligence Surveillance Act of 1978 it
was clear that there were powerful
forces within government and within
society
that wanted to burst the balance that
Congress had placed um certainly the
Reagan administration represented an
attempt to break those bounds the Reagan
administration of the iran-contra
scandal was in fact trying to break
these very bounds that had been placed
on the powers of the executive by
Congress um these and other acts which
had attempted to curtail the power of
the executive to act abroad were the
targets not only of the Reagan
administration but of people who had
been present at the at the moment when
these acts were passed as as key figures
in the in the late Nixon Ford
administration Richard Cheney and Don
Rumsfeld were people who clearly
believed that a grave grave grave wrong
had been done in limiting the power of
the President and they've spent their
whole career right up through the roles
they played in the present
administration trying to turn back the
clock very successfully obviously in the
last six or seven years so I think it
could be argued that this process has
now provoked this process of continued
accretion of power in the hands of the
executive has now provoked a reaction to
what many people call an imperial
presidency but I think you have to be
very I think you have to be very cold
and looking at this phenomenon of a
reaction to the re redefined infinitely
more potent executive and I think you
have to you have
see that really this is so far been just
essentially chatter
and no more talk about limiting the
power of the executive so far there has
been absolutely no action to reverse one
single action one single law one single
prerogative arrogated to the president
by his helpers handlers enablers by the
Congress or by anybody else in this
society and it doesn't seem to me from
what I've seen in the presidential
campaign so far as if there will be much
done in the next administration to roll
back some of these accretions of
presidential power we will see but the
the the the indices will be things like
the defense budget the indices will be
the military footprint of the United
States the indices will be the power of
the state to listen in on everything we
say and do if it decides for some reason
that we are a danger and I I wonder
whether in fact we will see the kind of
rollback after Iraq if Iraq ends as we
saw after Vietnam
let me move now to my third and last
substantive point which is is the United
States an empire and if so when did it
become one the conventional wisdom I'm
sorry my third point is not that my
third point is how does this unipolar I
apologize my third point is how does
this unipolar system that we are now
blessed with different from the bipolar
system that preceded it during the Cold
War the conventional wisdom regarding
the Cold War is that the United States
in the Soviet Union
essentially balanced one another off yes
this is true in that the u.s. nuclear
monopoly until 1949 was matched by a
vast superiority to the Soviet Union and
conventional forces yes this idea of
some kind of balance is true in that
even though the United States encircled
the Soviet Union rather than the other
way around
they didn't contain us we contained them
the Soviet Union still had the power
through its own forces in Europe or
through its allies in East Asia to break
out of that
containment out of that encirclement
after Sputnik and after the development
of intercontinental ballistic missiles
both powers had the capacity to destroy
one another and we had a nuclear balance
of terror so in all of those senses
there is some truth to this conventional
wisdom of the United States and the
Soviet units one another I would point
out to you however that in other areas
this was simply not true look at
economics look not just at growth rates
look at that
sheer gargantuan size not only in the
American economy but of the other
economies that were incorporated into
the same system under Bretton Woods into
the same system with the dollar as the
basic currency all of the economies of
Europe or except obviously Eastern
Europe under Soviet occupation the major
economies of age of Asia starting with
Japan excluding of course China until
recently all of these together dwarfed
the Soviet economy and the economies of
all other states that had come in come
in as governments as I said the United
States at the end of World War two had
half a world GDP it's proportional GDP
has declined but the proportion of world
GDP within the ambit of the American
dominated economic system has over
always been overwhelmingly larger than
that of the so-called socialist system
second thing to look at is that even
though the Soviet Union had enormous
power in the areas i talked about
conventional weapons and later on a
formidable nuclear arsenal the united
states had bases and forces everywhere
even on the peripheries of the Soviet
youth with the exception of the odd
Soviet base in the Middle East or Africa
or Cuba that was not the case for the
Soviet Union
by contrast the Soviet Union was
generally in a position of having to
worry about could the United States
strike the Soviet mainland from bases
all around the Soviet Union whereas the
United States was not in the same
position and this was important not just
in terms of the nuclear balance between
them or the conventional balance between
them there's also important in terms of
projecting power and dominating regions
finally
I would argue that in a variety of
indices of state power
starting with economics in the basis but
also other intangible ones a cultural
cultural power the United States and its
allies were more powerful than the
Soviet Union certainly in the Middle
East the area that I know the most about
the United States appears in hindsight
almost to be a hegemonic power from the
pretty much from the beginning of the
Cold War oh it is it is it is it is
certainly the dominant power by the
1970s in the Middle East the Soviet
Union is still challenging it vigorously
in the 1970s as it's challenging
American power in Africa as it's
challenging American power it's so in
central aid in central Africa at Central
America in the 1980s but in the Middle
East and I would argue in most other
regions of the world the United States
appears to be the dominant power from
about the middle of the Cold War onwards
there is a contest but there is not much
of a context and you can see why this
happens with something like the American
capture of Egypt from the Soviets if you
look at what happened understand that
this had much more to do with the Cold
War much more to do with the United
States and the Soviet Union dueling for
influence in the Middle East than it had
to do with peace you might have noticed
that there is not peace between the
Arabs and the Israelis even though there
is peace between Egypt and Israel this
was in part of course about achieving in
the egyptian-israeli peace but if you
read Kissinger's memoirs if you look at
what he was trying to do he understood
that the United States had enormous
advantages and could just take the major
Arab country out of the Soviet column
and put it into the American column and
it proceeded to do that and it did that
with exactly the the panoply of weapons
that I've talked about the economic the
military and the cultural all of these
operated almost without almost without
fail to bring the most important Soviet
ally in the Arab world into an alliance
with the United States which has lasted
for almost three decades two and a half
decades now I could give you other
examples of indications in the Middle
East that the United States even if it
was not
hegemonic power during the Cold War
certainly was the dominant power Israeli
military dominance over the Arab
countries Israel was a proxy as the Arab
countries were proxies in several of
these Wars starting at 67 Israel won
them all handily in the end and this
again was something that was beneficial
to the United States in terms of its
Cold War rivalry with the Soviet Union
the control of oil the American position
inside the inside Arabia is cemented in
1933 President Roosevelt at death's door
goes to meet it Ben sounded in 1945 ten
weeks before he dies obviously Saudi
Arabia is considered a very important
country by the United States and ever
since the 30s
ever since the 30s Saudi Arabia has been
integral to the American system and
Saudi Arabia is only one of a number of
countries in which the United States has
achieved a paramount position insofar as
oil is concerned um
ironically it's only in the closing
phases of the Cold War and in the period
after the Cold War and the Iranian
Revolution that any real challenge to
American dominance in the region came
and it did not come from the Soviets or
from Soviet proxies it came from the
Iranian Islamic regime and its allies
now the Cold War system even if it was
dominated by the United States certainly
different from the interwar and
pre-world War one systems at least in
the Middle East and I would argue in
most of other regions of the globe
Britain was the dominant power for most
of the interwar period and for much of
the pre-world War one period but it
dominated a multipolar system in which
there were many challengers Germany
under the under the Kaiser and later on
Nazi German Germany France in various
periods Italy and so forth and Britain
faced strong nationalist resistance
nevertheless British domination was
clear during most of these most of these
most of this period by contrast in the
Cold War period there were obviously
only two powers it was a bipolar system
there was a high degree of polarization
which affected most countries in Middle
East and many other regions
and interestingly enough much
mobilisation of nationalism during the
height of the Cold War functioned along
Cold War lines nationalism was often
manipulated by or operated in alignment
with the superpowers in much of the
Middle East as a result I think we find
American dominance which I find quite
clear a very much masked the most
analysts and I think the many people in
the Middle East for most of the Cold War
I remember conversations in Beirut in
the late 70s in the early 80s with
people who are really quite
knowledgeable and they talked about the
Soviet Union is if it was in some
respects superior to the United States
in terms of power and ability to project
that power in the Middle East and I said
them what Middle East are you looking at
how can you possibly see the Soviet
Union as superior to the United States
it's massively inferior to the United
States in every major index of power
even where it has positions in the
Middle East these are countries which
are very early anti-communist their
regimes are anti communist the bathroom
in Iraq slaughtered communists whereas
in a country like Morocco a country like
Saudi Arabia a country like Israel any
of the countries aligned of the United
States the elites or capitalists through
and through they believed in the nature
of the American system they believed in
the nature of the world system dominated
by the United States they were
completely convinced allies of the
United States this was simply not true
of most Soviet clients in the Middle
East I would argue it was not true of
most Soviet clients in the world there
were exceptions Cuba obviously Nicaragua
a few others South Yemen but these were
really glaring exceptions even where
people adopted a socialist system they
were most definitely not communists and
many of them were very limp
anti-communist certainly in the Middle
East and I think this is this is
important to recognize um only really I
think after the end of the Cold War when
we looked back did some analysts say
well you know the United States actually
was stronger than it appeared to us at
the time and and as we look back now I
think that
American American power was even greater
than I thought at the time let me
conclude by talking about where all of
this may take us my my injunction I'm
not going to predict the future I don't
I can't do that I don't do that it's
very clear this is clear that the end of
the Cold War which might have and by any
rational by any rational calculation
should have brought a peace dividend
which might have and by any rational
calculation should have brought a major
profound change in behaviors and in the
nature of the international system the
end of the Cold War did no such thing it
didn't bring an end to US bases around
the world whose existence had been
justified by the Soviet threat it didn't
bring a change in the American presence
in many parts of the world it certainly
didn't bring a fundamental change to the
American defense budget the Gulf War the
first Gulf War the various interventions
in the Balkans the the various ideas put
forward by liberal interventionists
which seemed to me to be a justification
of the United States behaving in exactly
the same way on different pretexts as it
behaved during the Cold War and now the
Global War on Terror the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan all of these things
these occupations these wars this new
presence justified on these bases have
all combined to leave the United States
in largely the same position as it was
in when a lethally armed Soviet Union
that actually could destroy the United
States and actually posed an existential
threat to our existence in this country
existed we're told that the the war on
terror involves a threat of the level of
world war ii and i just would remind you
or or the Cold War for that man I would
just remind you that in World War two
you had powers that had ambitions to
dominate the entire world impose their
system and might have had the capability
to do that there was in other words an
existential threat the Cold War
similarly involved a confrontation
between powers that could have destroyed
each other both of their society and
much of the known world there was in
other words an existential threat now
terrorism poses an awful threat to the
security of many thousands maybe tens of
thousands of individuals but it does not
pose an existential threat to this
society or as far as I can tell most
societies it is not as far as I can tell
by any rational calculation on anything
like the same level of danger to our
existence as societies as free people as
individuals in the mass as either the
totalitarian regimes of world war ii or
the the Cold War a nuclear standoff
between the United States and the Soviet
Union was nevertheless we as I say as I
suggested um the peace dividend has not
come about the changes in behavior that
I've talked about have occurred about
it's as if the engine of a car
disappeared but the car just kept
rolling along without an engine I mean
all of this was justified once upon a
time by the Cold War the Soviet right
communism remember many of you may be
too young to remember there was once
upon a time a thing called communism in
the Soviet Union it disappeared 1819
years ago but it was a big deal and
there was the justification for
everything the United States did
everywhere every base every foreign aid
bill the National Defense of pretend to
Education Act on the basis of which many
of us were trained in foreign languages
and so on so all of this was justified
by the cold war cold war and some of
your dissipate the Soviet Union
disappears nothing changes the vehicle
just keeps rolling on as if nothing had
happened something is in there under the
hood but it's not the Cold War it's not
the Soviet Union whatever it may be the
Cold War has been replaced by whatever
it is that the United States is facing
whether it's as some people say
Islamofascism or whether it is a global
war on terror or whether it is simply
several discrete separate specific wars
in specific places and specific
terrorist threats however you define it
something holds up this system and we
now seem to be moving into what appears
to be a cold war with Iran focused
around terrorism focused around nuclear
issues focused on a number of things
and all of this apparently serves to
fulfill the function previously served
by the Soviet Union justifying a defense
budget justifying bases all over the
world justifying a forward military
policy things like the Africa Command
and if you look carefully the Middle
East is central to much of this um now
we know anybody who pays any attention
to the American budget knows that there
are powerful and the budget process and
how the budget is produced everybody who
looks at these things carefully knows
that there are powerful economic and
political interests that are at stake in
all of this there is a plane called the
FA 22 wrapped or which is built in more
States than I can name which therefore
has more Congress and more senators
allied to its continuing construction
than I can make this is a plane which at
one point was supposed to cost under 100
million dollars a pop was then budgeted
225 million dollars a pop its opponents
now say that the unit cost of this
single airplane has gone up to 355
million a pop each individual airplane
will cost 350 five million dollars if
this estimation is correct this was a
aircraft which was designed to achieve
air superiority over the red Air Force
that is to say for those of you don't
know what the red Air Force is the Air
Force of the defunct Soviet Union we are
building sheep ships designed to achieve
superiority over the red Navy which is
rusting to the bottom of the Black Sea
and the Baltic even as we speak this is
obviously a process which has a ursa
dynamism a force to it
which is beyond discussion in rational
terms it's not clear how any of these
things would be in use in actual wars in
which the United States is engaged in
Iraq and Afghanistan wherever but these
these weapon systems are still being
built most of the things that are still
being built the the Osprey I don't know
if you if you're a fan of tilt-rotor
aircraft the Osprey was just entered
into service it's a it's a sort of a
helicopter it can both fly
and like an airplane and land cost
humongous amounts of money it has one
weakness it's vulnerable to desert
climates and actually not kidding
and they are building a large number of
these at costs that would make you know
make it easy to educate everybody for
free in this country very well and you
wouldn't have to pay all those loans if
we stopped building and they won't work
very well I promise you they they crash
during tests and so on and so so we have
a process which clearly doesn't work
very well now if you look at an article
that was written by a very very famous
historian by the name of the Manuel
Wallerstein entitled the eagle has
crash-landed she published in foreign
policy in the July August 2002 issue
you'll see the argument that these kinds
of military expenditures have in the
past sapped other great empires and that
they are already harming the United
States in comparison to its rivals
Wallerstein who is the is the person who
first developed and proposed the idea of
world systems and looking at a very long
period of time argues that over a very
long period of time these kinds of
pointless wasteful military expenditures
will harm the United States and these
are things that Americans rivals Russia
India China Europe and so forth are not
doing they're spending less they're
spending much less as a share of their
GDP all have higher growth rates and all
he argues will sooner or later reap the
benefits of not making this kind of
foolish expenditures we will see what
all of this means for the future um many
authors Colin Murphy whose book are we
wrong I mentioned to you and others
suggest that superior military power in
fact can keep an empire on top for a
while
Immanuel Wallerstein analysis and that
of others says the opposite certainly
the United States has unrivaled military
power however one of the things that the
war is that this country is fighting in
Afghanistan and Iraq has shown is that
with that kind of overwhelming power
comes the natural inclination
an opponent to use asymmetrical warfare
to use means that are not going to bring
that opponent face to face with the
crushing power that the United States
can bring to bear and I think the
outcomes that my generation witnessed as
teenagers and college students in
Vietnam and that your generation I think
may well witness in Iraq and in
Afghanistan over the medium term will
show that perhaps military power is not
capable of determining outcomes always
and everywhere in any case you will be
able to judge for yourselves within a
few years if the pendulum will swing
back to a more modest world role for the
United States I would suggest to you
that when you look at whether that is
happening you consider my metaphor of
the Middle East as a canary in the coal
mine if the United States has large
numbers of military forces and many
bases in the Middle East that diminution
of American power that more modest
position of the United States and the
world will not have been achieved or you
will see if the United States does
against all logic decide to keep a
long-term military presence in Iraq
whether in fact this will prove to be
sustainable and what other outcomes may
result from that or having to prevent
what other military adventures whether
in Iran or elsewhere the United States
will enter into whether the United
States is an empire or not I actually do
not know I'm not going to answer that
question for you I will say however that
the United States has in some respects
truly untrammeled power it's the most
powerful state in human history but at
the same time there are clear areas
where that power is simply unable to
dictate outcomes I think that the Middle
East may prove to be one of those areas
and so I suggest you look very carefully
at it in the future thank you very much